I mean yeah I mean I'll tell you about
my audition I had yesterday
ya know speaking of P and we're like
bodily fluids and stream so I was
watching like a hand stocking sketch
yeah just hold on I think I turned on
your stream right when you were doing
this yeah yes I was like going through
her sketches and the did you get that
you watched till the one where she's
like staying home while she's sick
mm-hm I don't know I didn't like I don't
have any strong feelings about it I was
just kind of curious like like what's on
her channel no no let's bash on this
[ __ ] no I love that yeah no I mean like
on stream like like I think people were
expecting me to have more jokes you know
just genuinely more curious like what
are these like or like are they as bad
as Leila's probably because it's like
shots to do stuff well that's what
people don't understand about that's
cringes we film for four hours oh yeah
yeah and I edit it into 12 minutes yeah
it's a lot of silence yeah yeah I think
it's a six hour shoot of us just and a
half of the time is that's just sitting
there thinking of jokes if we would have
put on the Dragon Ball Z glasses and
said 400 now that's the one let's get
that you get you see like our low IQ
going to work no hard we're thinking
about a joke anyway sorry
no no it's fine it's so like we get to
one in the the sketch is uh something
about staying home from school okay it's
like dude I don't understand the writing
on any of these like they're cut like
it's a concept of like a nine year old
or even younger like it's like and then
and then and then that's just what the
bits feel like so anyway it opens up
with her vlogging he's gonna like it she
goes what's up Hannah nation and oh my
oh [ __ ] oh god my there's a whole nation
entire country dedicated to Hannah
stalking somewhere that's terrifying
what does that look like just so I'm not
dedicated yeah no actually it's a
totality totality totalitarian Italian
terrorist yeah it's a it's a regime yeah
it's like a fascist regime where she is
the leader so it is dedicated to her
little bunch of eight-year-olds and
[ __ ] merch and the held prisoner
somewhere and so like it cuts away from
this vlog like angle to her barely older
than her dad mm-hmm
and like a gag and the entire sketches
him walking up to her room there's just
a miscellaneous like candle holder from
the ceiling that he runs his head into
every time it's like bad slapstick Wow
yeah just every time he goes to a room
thing you know and it's like it's just
this rinse repeat thing of like I have a
cop no you don't I have a temperature
and now you don't like it the dialogue
leads up like a porn yeah like he sits
down he's like oh my baby girl is a
temperature like weird incest porn yeah
and he like kind of like puts his hand
on her head and he takes it away and I
like the stop did it I'm like I'm like
better check my thermometer you know I'm
just you know whatever is sewed on that
under yeah and sure enough like he pulls
his dick out he starts railing and I
realized I was actually on pornhub
somebody gave me a pornhub link and I
wasn't Hannah stock I was jerking off on
stream yeah my accident though you
understand you know really does it dude
was like watching porn on stream and he
realizes he's live he's like oh my god
that is [ __ ] nightmare
holy [ __ ] yeah he's just like sitting
there like definitely had his pants down
and like like kind of goes oh and then I
think he was like whacking it on a break
like he was doing like a long stream
like this not he was like like head is
like screen up for like a break and was
just fully like about a yeah and that's
just instant like that's just so bad yep
because instantly
that's however many thousands of people
that have that clip now that's just
forever gonna be yeah all 100,000 people
who hear this she's exactly just trying
to live it down yeah sorry man but
somebody said I work here
on earth that again have everybody nine
years ago when streaming was present in
our unearthing it again was I gonna move
again so we get to my that's the podcast
yeah so in this sketch it gets to a
point where she like fakes throw up yeah
you know it was funny was like as I was
watching it on stream people were
calling [ __ ] out like why wouldn't you
do this I'm like yeah it totally makes
it and then that was the next thing in
the sketch my god damn dishes [ __ ]
predictable huh like so stupid
we ghosts are like she gets oatmeal and
like throws it like on her blanket as
like fake puke first of all oatmeal
looks nothing like puke yeah unless you
ate oatmeal yeah then it still you know
whatever what happens next you could do
in real life
yeah so her dad pulls up and he's like
oh does it seem like puke and takes the
spoon and spoons the oatmeal and eats it
because he yeah I do as a dad yeah yeah
well any any I think you just kind of a
good rule of thumb any any unknown
substance on the street or in a motel
for example yeah yeah I give it a little
taste
you don't know visually no you know I
mean you your eyes don't have the same
mm-hmm its distinguishing yeah
Sensibility
yeah that's your mouth has yeah so it's
good you just stick in your mouth yes
what we were taught
mmm-hmm growing up yeah that's you know
you know the song go ahead and put it in
your mouth put it in your mouth put it
in your mouth put it in your mouth is
jizz as a poo
no no just by looking put it in your
mouth that old classic song yeah
is it jizz is it poo might be really
good for you put it in your mouth put it
in your mouth is it dad or is it moms
you got to know what's going on put it
in your mouth put it in your mouth
a lot of ways is the moms is it Uncle
Tom's in your mouth if it's Uncle Tom's
don't worry it's not wrong put it in
your mouth okay class and remember
or is it pastor Shawn's imagining a
teacher going off about it remember
ladies don't sing this song to your
parents it's just our little secret
oh my god that's wrong yes oh he eats it
[Music]
[Music]
is